hello everyone my name is dr. Miller and
today the SCP were going to be looking
at is SCP 49er object class Keter
special containment procedures SCP 49 is
to be contained within a hermetically
sealed glass containment cell at site 77
the seals on this chamber are to be
checked and maintained every eight hours
and the defects in the chambers seal are
to be considered an emergency level
event and must be repaired immediately
by assigned containment engineers under
no circumstances are any individuals to
enter a CP 49s containment cell or
interact with the exterior of scp-1432
whitman interaction with SCP 49 is
forbidden to anyone except qualified
research personnel any individual who
shows signs of illness after interacting
with SCP 49 or after maintaining SCP 49
s containment cell is to be immediately
moved to an on-site medical quarantine
for evaluation
individuals who show symptoms of the
pathogen 0 for 9 Yersinia inactive are
to be kept in quarantine or further
analysis individuals who show symptoms
of the pathogen 0 for 9 Yersinia active
are to be moved to a hospice quarantine
and held there until they are deceased
the bodies of individuals affected by 0
for 9 your seniya inactive or active are
to be incinerated and the ashes placed
in sealed containers or further analysis
in the event of a breach of containment
site 77 is to be immediately evacuated
and all personnel screened for the
existence of 0 for 9 years in iam before
transfer off-site individuals found to
be infected with 0 for 9 years senior
are to be moved to quarantine in the
event that no proper screening procedure
can be initiated all personnel are to be
contained within site-77
to begin experimental drug trials see
addendum 49 349 Blackwater protocol for
details any individual attempting to
leave site 77 during an SCP 49
containment breach lockdown is to be
terminated on-site description SCP 49 is
a humanoid entity roughly 1.9 meters in
height which bears the appearance of a
medieval plague doctor while SCP 49
wears thick robes and the ceramic mask
indicative of that profession the
garments appear to have fused onto SCP
49 s body over time and are now nearly
indistinguishable from whatever form is
beneath the rows x-rays indicate that
while SCP 49 does have a vaguely human
skeleton beneath its outer layer there
are several major differences and the
entire skeletal structure appears to
have been severely damaged at some point
in the past contact with SCP 49 as well
as coming within a certain distance in
open air and being exposed to surfaces
SCP 49 has recently touched or
come into contact with will invariably
result in the affected person suffering
from an extremely virulent infection of
the uranium pestis bacterium footnote
bubonic plague the exact means of
exposure are currently poorly understood
however it is believed that the
bacterium have evolved over time to not
simply spread quickly with significantly
more aggressive symptoms but also
actively seek out non infected hosts
individuals exposed to SCP 49s anomalous
strain of bacteria 0 for 9 years Senya
well always become infected footnote
researchers currently believe that as
little as 5 parts per billion in open
air is enough to infect an entire room
of subjects infected individuals can
then be identified as having one of two
types of the pathogen 0 for 9 your sania
active or inactive individuals affected
with 0 for 9 years senior inactive will
briefly experience flu-like symptoms but
will eventually recover and feel no
additional ill effects these individuals
however can still spread the anomalous
disease and will continue to do so even
after recovery there is currently no
known cure for 0 for 9 years senior
individuals infected with 0 for 9 years
senior active will experience similar
flu-like symptoms that instead of
subsiding after a few days will become
dramatically worse over the course of
several months individuals infected with
0 for non Yersinia active will
experience severe nausea fever sweating
palpitations lesions hardening and
flaking of the skin bleeding annexes
from the eyes nose and ears broken bones
due to severe muscle contractions
extreme neurological pain swelling of
the legs and feet swelling of the
internal organs blindness paralysis and
eventually death
throughout the duration of the sickness
which typically lasts between two to
five months untreated and longer if
administered symptom alleviating care
individuals will continue to spread the
zero for 9 years sinning bacteria only
ceasing production of the bacteria after
their death due to the build-up of the
bacteria within the Bonnies of the
afflicted the corpses of 0 for 9 your
Cine of victims are extremely toxic and
must be incinerated immediately after
death it is unknown if the ashes of
deceased individuals are also contagious
as CP 49 is sentient and will respond to
questioning it speaks rudimentary French
and understands small amounts of English
but as typically heard speaking to
itself in an Eastern European dialect of
unknown origin as CP 49 has not been
forthcoming about its origins or the
nature of zero for nine years senior
addendum 0 for 9.1 discovery SCP 49 was
discovered during an archeological
investigation of a medieval site near
orleans france the archaeological team
reported digging beneath the ruins of a
collapsed Church and finding a man there
after bringing SCP 49 out from under the
church one of the archaeologists
attempted to remove a CP 49s mask
resulting in the entity becoming hostile
and attacking the team with sharpened
steel spikes worn on its fingers after
intervention by local police was unable
to apprehend SCP 49 and gun fire was
unable to subdue the entity foundation
assets embedded within the French
military intervened and attempted to
contain the entity
shortly after doing so and after
examination of the archaeological team
and the law enforcement officials who
had responded to their call every
individual who had come into contact
with or had been exposed to someone who
had come into contact with SCP 49 began
showing signs of zero for 9 years cineon
fection after analysis by foundation
hazmat teams all individuals and as ap
49 were moved to quarantine two nearby
farmers who had come across the scene
were not found until three days later by
which time they and their families had
all been infected by zero for 9 years
Cinna
after a full exposure analysis hazard
teams concluded that no other infected
individuals remained outside of
foundation containment addendum zero for
9.2 initial processing interview playing
log now
can you communicate what do you speak
speak yes what is this place you're
being held here for a domination what
did you do to those men those men the
men who found you the ones who are sick
no not sick being cured what I have seen
horrible things the darkness that swept
over my house and turned my people to
ash a great pass to us suffering without
end I did what I could but so many
perished so many turn their eyes and did
nothing
what do you mean did nothing the sick
pride outside and they were stepped over
abandoned fear overcame empathy they
rotted and died their flesh cries out
from the ground for comfort for
compassion for justice I tried and that
was punished for it broken for it
beaten how can we cure those men
what are they sick with they are sick
with apathy as are you all I have
festered in the darkness for a thousand
years the dead cry out for a reckoning
and then we'll have it
I will have it what do you say the best
salons was never the sickness the
sickness is human nature and there are
the newsstand untouched by its grasp
you're sick sir you were all sick and I
am The Cure and this concludes this
lecture thank you all very much for
listening
you were all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
tiber ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]